la première concertation du projet
européen gare bécane de la verrière a
démarré en fanfare samedi dernier autour
des tables verrier roi et lui est maître
d'ouvragé
le projet comprend l'aménagement du
l'âge de l'achever de l'âme allemande
la nationale automatiquement quelques
mois on our a donné la parole aux
verriers roi c'était le but de cette
première concertation les élus
recueillait les attentes
les réflexions mais aussi des critiques
de la population on parle de notre
expérience est justement fait en fait on
définit ce qui est positif dans la ville
ce qui l'est moins ce qui est négatif et
on s'appuie sur eux sur cette réflexion
justement pour à terme en fait proposé
proposer des solutions mais on est
vraiment là dans la phase diagnostic
la démarche est très intéressante parce
que ça là on s'engage pour les dix ans
je verrai peut-être pas le cette ville
mais c'est intéressant de partir de
d'une friche des friches agricoles pour
arriver à une ville nouvelle
dans ce projet priorité aux logements
sociaux mais aussi au développement des
transports afin de désenclaver la ville
de plus l'installation d'une zone
d'activité permettrait de multiplier les
offres d'emploi dans une commune
particulièrement marquée par le chômage
pour autant la question d'augmenter les
impôts le projet serait financé par des
partenaires publics et privés et les
nouveaux arrivants
d'autres ateliers de concertation plus
approfondie devra se dérouler dès le
mois de février